>>Student: Jazmin feels like she's
going to get into a good college and--
>>Crystal: Because we do
collaborative reading,
we are helping every
scholar feel successful,
regardless of the reading level.
>>So who is it about?
>>Student: Jazmin.
>>Crystal: Being able to
synthesize the big ideas,
form opinions, and share those.
Those are skills that any contributing
citizen of the world would need.
>>Student: What do you think about that?
>>Alexa: Our mission is to
create critical thinkers,
children that are able to communicate
clearly their thoughts, their ideas
and as a result, are
productive members of society.
>>Crystal: Collaborative reading is a
reading approach where the scholars work
with one another and share ideas.
>>Student: Little cat was
walking down the street.
>>Crystal: It's amazing
because the kids are coming
in at different levels,
different learning styles.
So whether you're a higher
reader or lower reader,
we're all going to break
it down together.
>>Student: Why is this important?
>>Student: Because we want to
better understand the text.
>>Genesis: What I like most
about collaborative reading is you
take all your ideas, put them together,
and make one big thought.
We all understand it.
>>Crystal: Scholars, we're
ready for collaborative reading.
>>The structure of collaborative
reading is broken into five phases.
Each day is concentrating
on a specific skill or idea.
>>Raquel: Each phase has a
question tailored to that skill
that we want them to walk away with.
>>Student: We're going to do phase one.
We're going to look for the
main idea in chapter eight.
>>Students: I went directly
to her office
to ask how this obvious
mistake had occurred.
>>Mia: So the text we've been reading
is a book called Jazmin's Notebook.
Jazmin wants to be a writer, Ms. Wise,
this counsellor, wants her to stay
at home, clean, cook, and
to not follow her dreams.
>>Students: -- that a person
like yourself would be happier
doing something with your hands.
>>Raquel: After we read it, we go
back to what was the main idea.
Because if they understand that point,
then it'll be easier
for them to build on it.
>>Student: Okay. So it's not
D. So we're stuck with B or C.
>>Student: C says Jazmin didn't
believe she might get to college, but--
>>Mia: We'll choose an
answer. We'll discuss it
with the class to see if we agree.
>>Student: Why do you guys think it's B?
>>Student: The courses Ms. Wise
picked for her will be fitting
for her career as a best-selling author.
>>Student: Phase two is annotating
the text for better understanding.
We do it chunk by chunk, and we annotate
key details that supports the gist.
>>Raquel: This gives students an
opportunity to really dissect.
Some of the annotation
markings are a star
if there's a section
that's really vital,
arched arrows connecting
ideas, question marks.
By phase three, now we're going to
go back, look at those annotations.
What inferences can we make here?
>>We're going to go back to our
text to answer some questions.
>>Student: It could be
A and it could be B.
>>Student: I'm leaning more towards A.
>>Does everybody have a answer?
>>Students: Yes.
>>Student: Why do you guys
think it's A and not B, C, or D?
>>Student: She thinks Jazmin
is not going to go to college.
You could infer that she
doesn't believe in her.
>>Raquel: Phase four, now, we're
looking closely at the author's craft.
So what was the message that was being
conveyed with certain words or phrases?
>>Student: Me and her annotated
that her name is very, like,
ironic because she's not
that wise as her name says
because Jazmin doesn't want to do
the courses she put her in to do.
>>Raquel: Phase five is about
bringing it all together.
So they are thinking about a theme
or drawing conclusions why the
author wrote what he wrote.
>>Student: Summary of this excerpt would
be Ms. Wise controlling Jazmin's life.
>>Raquel: So what goes after your claim?
>>The way that we select texts for
collaborative reading, we look at texts
that are grade level
and above grade level.
So this approach is a perfect way
for scholars to feel successful even
if they are below and for us to push
those who are already on grade level.
>>Mia: My favorite thing about
collaborative reading is that,
since we all hear other people's
ideas, we have a better understanding.
And also, we have multiple
days to figure out the meaning.
>>Crystal: Because we do collaborative
readings, scholars get access
to literacy in so many different ways.
It's through their sharing
and their discussion,
the process of the collaborative
reading.